National Geographic asked me to
specifically go and do the elements that
we partake in with water related to our
spiritual thirst this was a massive
amount of place I think it was 13
countries total you go there and you
wait and come across the things that
sort of hopefully magically and
naturally happen this is a Shinto
cleansing ceremony in Japan this was one
of these events where I just wasn't
expecting something like this playing
out suddenly you know people start
showing up and putting candles all over
this magnificent Rock edifice and it
just created this absolute brilliant
scene that I could never have imagined
with water flowing you sort of wanna
show that it's flowing and moving but I
don't consciously think I need to do
this and I need to do that or think this
or think that you know I do everything
on a I haven't got a clue
it just happens this way I'm not doing
anything it's it's the the brilliance of
the people and the magnificence and
majesty of the location and all the
stars are lining up that really make all
of this fall into a ink and paper in a
magnificent magazine like National
Geographic I don't do this it does it
itself
with a sacred water story I hope it will
you know tap the consciousness if you
tap the consciousness of one you've done
more than none
and all you can do is one by one by one
don't know if we'll ever tap the
consciousness of all but it's at least
if I can do one then I've done my job